KENTUCKY DERPY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> ARE YOU GETTING WARMED UP?
WHAT ARE YOU WARMING UP FOR,
JARED?
>> I AM GETTING MY BODY READY
FOR THIS ROUND.
HE IS HAVING A SLOW STROKE.
>> HE SEEMS FINE, HE SEEMS FINE.
>> HELP HIM HIT THE BUZZER.
>> I SMELL PENNIES.
DO YOU GUYS?
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT.
WAS IT PENNY MARSHAL.
>> ALL RIGHT.
.. THIS WEEKEND WAS THE KENTUCKY
DERBY, I WAS BORN IN LOUISVILLE,
KENTUCKY SO IN IS MILDLY
IMPORTANT TO ME.
IT'S LESS OF A HORSE RACE AND
MORE OF AN EXCUSE TO GET DRUNK
AND WEAR OUTFITS AND POST IT ON
SOCIAL MEDIA LIKE THIS GUY HERE.
OH!
>> SHUT UP, BITCH, I'M DRIVING!
>> LET'S GET SOME MORE WINE
BOXES.
>> HASHTAG DERBY. THE
WINNING HORSE BY THE WAY WAS
CALIFORNIA CHROME AND THE RACE
INCLUDED A HORSE NAMED GENERAL
AROD AND CANDY BOY. I FEEL LIKE
WE COULD COME UP WITH BETTER
HORSE NAMES THAN THAT.
60-SECONDS ON THE CLOCK AND I
WANT AS MANY RIDICULOUS HORSE
NAMES AS POSSIBLE. GO!
>> JAMIE.
>> HAY, RIGHTS ACTIVIST.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JARED.
>> SECRETARIAT APPRECIATION DAY.
>> Chris: NICE, POINTS.
YES, JARED.
>> DAVID HASSLE-HOOF.
>> Chris: SO GOOD.
>> YES, THE FAMOUS GUY.
>> Chris: I'M SORRY, WAS HE ON
HAY-WATCH?
>> HE WAS ON NIGHT HORSE RIDER.
>> Chris: SO GOOD!
>> HAY, THAT WAS GOOD!
>> Chris: POINTS. DAN.
>> CIRCUS (BLEEP)!
>> THAT IS ACTUALLY MY FAVORITE
PINKBERRY FLAVOR.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JARED.
>> NAY-Z.
>> Chris: POINTS.
REAL GOOD, JAMIE.
>> GLUEY CK.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JARED.
>> MNAY SHYAMALAN.
>> THERE ARE A LOT A FAMOUS
PEOPLE WITH NAY IN IT.
>> YOU THINK THE HORSE IS GOING
TO FINISH THE RACE AND
SOMETHING (BLEEP) AND WEIRD
HAPPENS.
>> SEAN HOOFY COMBS.
>> YES.
SO GOOD, POINT.
>> Chris: JARED.
>> MONEY LAUNDERING SCHEME.
>> Chris: YEAH, OKAY.
I GET IT.
DAN.
>> JOY-LESS BEHAR.
>> Chris: NICE.
POINTS.
>> LASO COMIC STANDING